[Music]  now I want you to to get good rest what  if they have a bad dream I'm sure we can  handle any dream you have like if I  dream that you sent us away into the  dark and me really hurt I'm so sad is  scared of the dark out there like  poisoning me for years and years I can  tell my blood turns into poison and my  heart breaks right in half and I can't  feel anything happy  I can't stand it anymore a night they  have to die  and time on a silver cable  it's my job I urge shut  [Music]  did you wake us up from a dream like  that  we're not like any other family we're  different  because of where we grew up  Hill House  your mother she was not crazy  neither was her sister neither is her  brother neither are you  it's that house  [Music]  you don't have to worry now sweetie that  really bad dream of course I'd wake  [Music]